interesting you're looking forward to
the election then so you're gonna be
voting for it tomorrow I shall be and
why are you looking forward to an
election so much I think the House of
Commons is dominated by people who wish
to remain despite them most of them
being the Parliament when we voted for a
referendum when we changed our position
from being representatives thinking
about owing people in our best judgment
to on this issue saying we're going to
be you you tell us and we're delegates
and we will carry it through you know
lose your seat in the election though
but I I'm going in to win and we will
see it's getting difficult it's not a
marginal seat so I haven't got lots of
liberals and and Tory votes to scoop up
behind me but I am confident that I will
win that seat labour of course have been
resisting backing an early election so
far absolutely not I said it's nothing
to do with the polls it's nothing about
whether or not they can win it's all
about trying to make sure that no deal
is off the table
the MPs I know had a pretty sick the
thought of having the election so people
will vote against it I'm it's an old
hackneyed phrase isn't it but turkeys
don't vote for Christmas unless you're
do my old fashioned liberals and you did
and Michael foot and you saw what the
consequences were so I think we should
have one and we do obviously need to get
the bill through but we don't need that
amount of time I hope the European Union
gives us a two-week extension and
there's much there to discuss of the
importance but other people are going to
use this time but we have in the
committee stage to say we must have
another referendum these are people who
agreed the referendum haven't accepted
the result of the referendum and now say
we have ought to have another referenda
it's absolutely farcical they're big
issues to decide but they won't take
more than two week
in committee we should get the bill
through and then we should have an
election now you've called voted to
leave the EU you also voted for Boris
Johnson's brats that deal
did you just wait for the deal because
you want brexit to be done or because
you actually think it's a good deal that
has been negotiated no I mean it's not
the most brilliant deal I think it's
worse than the may deal but all the
people who vote against the made deal
and now complain against this deal so
I'm it's just that's what goes on in
Parliament but it's not Boris Johnson's
deal we had a referendum that people
spoke both parties committed themselves
to accept that referendum result both
parties put in their election manifestos
that they would actually carry that
result through so I voted for the
referendum bill there on one occasion
when I was voting for missus for the the
deal that mrs. mate put forward to
fulfil the referendum decision she came
up and said thank you for being in my
lobby tonight Frank I said oh no no
promise you're in my lobby I've always
been on balance in favor of leaving
where she'd been somebody who had
actually been against leaving said she
switched to your corner she had indeed
and if the bill is gonna have any chance
of getting through it's gonna need a lot
of your former colleagues in labour to
support it do you think that there are
the numbers there or do you worry that
some of those who second reading may
actually fall away as it continues its
passage yes when sort of a let win put
forward his amendment to extend the time
the analysis that's been done on the
people who voted for that three-quarters
of those who voted yet very yet another
extension were people who are committed
to remain so we've got remaining
supporters appearing in brexit clothing
but their aim is to wreck the decision
of that referendum and my worry is about
having another long delay when we really
need a couple of weeks is all these
delays come out of what's called the
transition period
the period in which we want to negotiate
that free trade agreement with the
European Union
we've already had two extensions that
time has come off the really important
period that once we passed the
legislation we then get on to the
detailed negotiations as to what our
relationship with Europe will be and for
that I've always been in favor of a free
trade agreement now you have spent many
years campaigning about modern-day
slavery 39 people with us being found in
the back of a refrigerated trailer I
mean we don't know the circumstances of
these individuals of course we can know
them pretty pretty well I mean people
now are so desperate wanting to come
here because there's it's a great
country to be in despite politicians
crapping away all the time about
implementing the referendum decision
when they get to the UK where do they go
well I mean the report showed that there
would have been if this has been a
successful cargo if those poor wretches
had actually been alive there would be
many buses to actually meet that van and
take them off into the into this prior
light zone of really modern slavery in
Britain and when three of us Elizabeth
but thus lost from the laws Maria Miller
colleague in the Commons myself we
review for the government how we should
strengthen the modern slavery Act and
we've kept going because we're looking
at the issue of whether our laws on
prostitution make it more favorable to
bring people here and then traffic them
further onto the continent or not but we
that's one thing that can no we had
officers from border control from our
ports as part of our inquiry and a
horrendous thing that they said was
unlike an airport where the border staff
get lists of who the people are in
advance the wave of lorries and cars and
what have you coming over they have no
idea whatever at all
about anybody coming in through the
ports so the three of us have asked for
an urgent meeting with the Home
Secretary if she's listening might she
Ashley IRA grant that request because
clearly it's very very very easy to
bring people into this country through
the ports it's much more difficult to
Jesus say through the airports and
therefore one of the things we need to
do is to look at what are the border
staff needing ports and then secondly
and the government's and and this
government previous government's
campaign against drugs has been
coordinated nationally bringing in our
secret services the Foreign Office the
police the border control staff to try
and make a job of preventing drugs
getting into this country now that group
does not exist to counter modern slavery
and one thing the government could do on
Monday would be to announce the House of
Commons you're not only going to have a
vote on the election but we've actually
now going to treat this as seriously as
we do drugs because they down to the
present time